- Right now, y'all, I
have a guy on the line
with four kids of his own.
He's a musician, Presidential
Medal of Freedom recipient,
and star of NCIS: Los Angeles.
Y'all check it out.
- Kendrick's backed out.
But you're so sure of these charges
that you feel absolutely
compelled to do this?
Destroy the character and career
of Chief Petty Officer Argento,
possibly put him in the brig for life?
- No, no, I'm not.
- Excuse me?
- Without Kendricks, I'm
not making a statement.
- So now you'll let a murderer go free.
- All right, y'all, so we have
him on the line right now.
Y'all say hello to LL Cool J.
What's up, LL?
- What up, what up, what up, what up?
- How are you doing?
- I'm good.
Hopefully you know everybody, I just want
to tell everybody out
there, I hope you're having
a safe quarantine, and your families
and friends are safe and healthy,
And for those who have gone
through it on a deeper level,
I want to send my words of encouragement.
Obviously condolences to those
who have lost loved ones.
- Yeah.
- You know, I'm just hanging in there.
I'm just home, you know.
We just doing what we do.
- Yeah.
Well, how is your family
doing with isolation, though?
Y'all, y'all hanging in there?
What do y'all do, play games?
What do y'all do?
- Well, well, first of all,
my kids are a lot older.
So I don't, you know,
two of my kids are out
East, and I'm out West.
But two are here with me.
But you know, they're kind of,
my daughter is doing her thing
with her you know, masks and
just trying to give to people.
My other daughter's kind of thinking
about her songwriting and writing songs.
And you know we just
kinda, we just cooped up,
huddled together in the house.
- Yeah.
- And just staying tight, staying close.
You know, try to eat dinner together.
That's something that wasn't
happening a lot, you know
before, because everybody was moving.
- Us as well, yeah.
- Yeah, so we..
- Yeah, that's .. The family time is,
the family connection
is actually pretty cool,
and that's cool that,
one of your daughters is
taking after you in the studio,
and then the other daughter is,
she's making masks for people?
- Yes, Samaria Leah she
has a clothing line as she does but, one
of the things she wanted to do was
she wanted to make these masks
and really help other people.
You know what I'm saying?
In that thought process.
And you know she did it
in like you know, a couple of weeks ago
I thought it was really
really good to see her,
you know, in that space you know,
just caring about how what
people are going through
and trying to you know, help help us all
follow these rules in a stylish way but
follow the rules nonetheless you know what
I'm saying, so that's cool.
- Absolutely and like what what a blessing
as a parent to have.
That must be a proud moment.
Like that they take the
time to think of others
in this time, instead of being selfish
and doing something for themselves,
that's a really cool thing.
There you've got good kids,
look you're a great dad.
Look at you, all right.
(Laughter)
- Go Daddy, it's your birthday.
(laughter)
- Oh, I know my birthday's coming up
and we're like celebrating quarantine.
(laughter)
- Happy birthday, happy birthday.
- Oh thank you it's coming up.
But I heard something funny
that I heard that you did
that I can't believe you did,
- Okay.
- And I wouldn't even do if I lost a dare,
you put your phone
number, on the internet?
- Yeah yeah people can hit me up,
you know what I'm saying 9175405512.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah yeah, I've been
texting with people,
I don't, I don't answer like
all the time all the time,
but I definitely answer people,
and connect with people
and try to send encouraging messages,
whether video or text and just,
just trying to keep people,
you know uplifted and
- Elevated, yeah.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
It's a really cool way to like,
just stay in touch with people
and just give people love.
I just wanted to connect
with the people and uh,
it was a great opportunity
to be able to do it,
and in a cool way.
And it really is true,
it really is my number
and it works so, it's cool.
- That's really cool of you.
So what is, what, what's
like your daily routine,
are you like, you work out a lot right?
- I do work out, I do work out.
Make sure my nose, I got, all right, yeah.
I definitely--
- I know me too I'm like aah.
- You know like I'm like yeah I work out,
like a, like a, I got a
hand hanging out my nose.
Like yeah, I've been working out lately
while two hair look this
holding up west side.
- Even one stray.
(laughter)
- I'm just be a guy just
with his haired nose ass
throwing up west side.
Um yes, so um, yeah I try work out.
Lately though,
I've really been you know,
trying to watch my diet,
just being a little bit more conscious
of what I'm eating.
Because you know, you know,
you can easily fall off a cliff,
doing...
- Oh I, by the way I have totally fallen.
I am so screwed, I'm gonna
leave Montana like 400 pounds.
I literally just got a Peloton.
Like that's why I risked
the bad hair for you.
I was like I have to have my
workout hair in this interview,
because if I don't work
out I'm gonna be so fat.
(laughter)
- 100 percent, 100 percent.
- And not even fat
really just so unhealthy.
So it's like it is hard
because we're right by
our kitchen all the time,
- Yeah.
- And so man, making sure
you're eating healthy,
that's really smart like
for your, your you know,
just your brain.
- Its good for your mind
too, its good for your mind,
trying to eat healthy.
And also trying to make
sure that I don't--
I come out of this better
than I went into it,
and just trying to read
and improve my mind
and just really just hone
in on my craft and just,
just be, use this as a chance to...
- Better yourself.
- Self improve. You know what I'm saying?
- That's such a positive
way of thinking about it and
I'm like gosh thank you for saying that
because I needed to hear that.
I wanted to go to this,
because you, you've still got
your Sirius radio channel right?
Rock the Bells? Going on right now so,
is there anything cool
'cause everybody's--
I wanted to talk about it
because everybody's
needing this distraction
and this entertainment
value, so like anything
cool coming up?
- Yeah I have,
I have a really cool thing I'm
doing with the Beastie Boys.
We're doing a town hall,
and we're gonna be talking
about their new documentary.
Really exciting.
And I'm gonna be talking
to Ad-Rock, you know
Mike D.
And we're gonna kind of just,
you know go through their
career, their lives,
working with Spike
Jones, what that was like
and when he directed
it and stuff like that.
So I'm doing that a little later on and...
- That's so cool.
- You know others than that,
I've really been using
Rock the Bells to like
let people know that all of those
Eric B. And Rakim fans, and those Big
Daddy Kane fans, and those Public Enemy
fans, and those Run DMC
fans, and those you know,
Beastie Boys fans, and those Eminem
fans, and those LL Cool J
fans, and those Ice fans.
There is a place where you
can hear all of that music
and you can still enjoy it.
Which is channel 43 on Sirius XM
and um...
- That's so cool 'cause it also
exposes people that might like one artist
to another artist.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, so that's--
- And people who are curious, right?
Like if you're just
curious, if you're not,
maybe hip-hop is not your main thing.
Maybe they're country fan,
maybe they're you know fans
of other music, that's fine.
If you're curious and wanna
hear what was going on,
where did this,
where did all that his
hip-hop stuff start?
Where did this classic hip-hop start?
That's a place to kind of go check it out
you know what I'm saying?
Just be ready 'cause it's you know,
it's raw, it's raw.
- Oh my gosh, I can't wait since you're,
all right, all right
- Rockefeller's raw and uncut, baby.
- I love that, I love it.
Okay, so I also read
'cause like everybody's
binge-watching now because, well,
not a lot to do at nighttime.
So I heard though, that NCIS LA,
y'all have actually been the top show
for binge watching right now.
- Yeah.
- Like the top show.
- Yeah, that was--
- I love your show.
My sister actually turned
me on to your show,
because I watched the
original with Mark Harmon
originally years ago,
and then my sister turned me on to y'alls
and it's so good.
That's kinda cool that
everybody's watching your stuff.
- Listen, I was pleasantly surprised and,
and I just want to say thank you
to all the fans that watch
and let 'em know that
we don't take that for granted.
I talked with the team,
the team all feels the same way.
It was kind of surprising,
we was like wow, okay cool.
It was a, it was a
really pleasant surprise
to know that the show was
doing so well right now.
But it really is comfort food.
We really--
- Yeah.
- You know it's about
the chemistry in the cast
it's about you know us just,
kind of sticking closely together,
we don't phone it in and it worked out.
So we'll see what happens moving forward
but it's definitely nice to know that
we are loved and appreciated now.
That was a pleasant
surprise, totally unexpected.
- You know what though, that,
that means it's just great.
It's good like, you know what I'm saying?
Like it's nothing else is doing
anything, it's just demand.
That's a powerful thing.
That's so cool for everybody
that works on the show
not just the actors, the writers,
everybody that works on it.
But anyway congratulations
on that, that's super cool.
- Thank you, thank you.
- All right, so did I also hear that
you're hosting a quarantine
show and it's on Instagram?
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm doing real people real
conversations on Instagram.
- Yeah.
- And real people real
conversations is basically I--
I go IG live with you know, real people.
Like I just pick people randomly,
go on IG live with them
and have conversations with
them about their lives,
what they're going through and it's great
and sometimes we have
a little game we play
called 'The Furious Five challenge.'
where they do a little
scavenger hunt around the house
(laughter)
and items.
And really it's just a way to again,
connect with the community,
connect with the people,
and also it lifts spirits,
you know what I'm saying?
Instead of me just hiding
away. So yeah. This--
- Absolutely, it breaks, it
breaks down those barriers.
So I love that you're
doing that. Thank you.
- Yeah, absolutely. It's a
beautiful thing to have really
had some fascinating
conversations I've had.
I mean I've also had guests come on.
Like I had Bishop TD Jakes come on,
I've had Judah Smith come
on, pastor Judah Smith.
I've had, you know a lot of
like I said regular people.
I've had, you know, hip-hop artists like
you know Eric Sermon of EPMD and Fat Joe
and all these different other artists.
So it's been, it's been amazing.
It's been real special.
N.O.R.E, N.O.R.E from Capone and Noreaga,
the rap group is come on, so.
It's been like a really
cool community thing
where people just feel connected,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah. And that's what we,
that's what we need now more than ever.
So, well thank you so much, Ll.
You're like, this is one
of my favorite interviews.
You're such a--
- I appreciate it.
- You're such a great human
and I really appreciate
like not only you doing this for us,
but like everybody that's gonna see this
you're definitely gonna inspire
and make feel better.
Which is the coolest thing ever, so.
But thank you.
Everyone y'all watch NCIS Los
Angeles this Sunday on CBS
and check out the Beastie Boys
Town Hall Monday, April 27th
on Rock the Bells Sirius XM channel 43.
Next it is fashion designer--
- You know what?
Can I say one thing about NCIS LA,
one last thing about NCIS LA.
This, this the season
finale that's coming up
is gonna be unbelievable.
We have some SEALs that were
accused of some heinous crimes
overseas and our team.
My character Sam Hanna
as a former Navy SEAL
he has to go over there along
with the rest of the team
and investigate these
crimes and it gets crazy.
So people should be ready for that.
Hedi is involved.
It's gonna be a strong,
a lot of strong, it's gonna be strong.
So people should check it out.
- Well they should check it out
we need this kind of stuff right.
We need this entertaining
stuff, so thank you.
- You're welcome.
- That was like an incredible tease.
- Thank you.
- They should be paying you more.
(laughter)